high school student kamila my afraid he
never leaves her home in Buenos Aires
without her green scarf it's a
politically charged symbol for her as
well as for tens of thousands of women
in Argentina who are fed up with the
country's culture of much she small
latent injustice every time a girl goes
missing or is raped or killed we not
only get angry but now we are organized
we've become a single voice that's heard
in schools everywhere so that this will
finally stop it's like a revolution
Camila has been involved in the jnana
menos movement since its inception new
anime knows Spanish for not one woman
less fights gender-based violence Mike
Fraley took part in huge pro-abortion
demonstrations in front of Argentina's
Parliament but the 17 year old also had
the opportunity to address
parliamentarians directly in a
passionate speech she demanded access to
safe and legal abortions for Argentinian
women Camila wants to change life
radically for her country women in their
fight to expand women's rights here the
women are not afraid to lock horns with
both the Catholic Church and with state
authorities they demand sex education
courses in all schools to see action
against sexual harassment we want people
to be talking about it and we want to
see an end to these incessant attacks in
discos on the streets and everywhere
else they're happening these passionate
young advocates are making a difference
parliamentarians are taking notice at
least some of them it's amazing what
these young women have achieved
parliamentarians are listening to their
own daughters who are making them
reconsider their views on abortion and
women's rights we have to support these
developments when young women are
willing to stand up for their rights
they help us create a fairer society are
you in phenomenal kolak they walk on
this phenomenal what these young women
are doing there's no other place in the
world where girls on 2
Tina so politically motivated so engaged
in the legislative process to fight for
free legal abortions they're just
teenagers students students like
Manfredi she plans to study anthropology
after school and to remain politically
active I will keep fighting because I
believe in my ideals in what I want for
society I don't know if I'll eventually
run for political office but I'm sure
that will continue to be out there on
the streets fighting for women's rights
but it goes like I'll say ok this
she's already achieved a lot even her
Catholic school classmates are convinced
they proudly wear their green scarves
whatever she decides Camila Manfredi
clearly has a political future ahead of
her